meghan mccain calls out her old view
co-host joy behar and compares her to a
drunk x we have to move on it all
unfolded on twitter after megan shared
this valentine's day snapshot with her
husband captioning it quote happy
valentine's day ben i love you and i'm
grateful every day for the life we have
together
that's when a twitter user commented
under megan's post writing quote does
every thought and sentiment need to be
on twitter and then enters joy who
responded to that comment writing quote
apparently
people like it that we argue they like
sad but they like conflict megan clapped
back at joy's statement writing quote oh
hey there joy i see you're spending your
afternoon creeping on my valentine's day
pic with your weirdo friend who sued abc
in a now deleted tweet megan added quote
leaving the view was like having exes
who won't stop drunk texting you we're
not being phony and i'm not trying to
placate to an audience the 37 year old
also wrote quote imagine spending your
valentine's day trolling your
ex-colleagues tweet about her husband
megan capped off her latest twitter feud
with joy by doubling down writing quote
it's pathetic and it creeps me out i'm
still not used to it it's been six
months since megan signed off from the
view this has been a really wild ride
the past four years of my life it's been
honestly the best of times and the worst
of times but it seems distance does not
make the heart grow fonder along with
this latest twitter battle megan turned
into an outspoken critic of the show
writing pieces about it for the daily
mail and discussing her time as a
co-host in her audio memoir bad
republican
something she opened up to et about in
october of last year
you say joining the view was a hazing
experience you also say working on the
view brings out the worst in people it
does i think if you're a view fan you
probably remember was was when joey told
me she didn't miss me and that she did
miss me zero you treated me so much when
i was on maternity leave you missed me
so much you missed fighting with me
i did not miss you
okay and i was going through postpartum
anxiety i had just come back from
attorney leave it was my second day back
and it was sort of bookended between
that moment when i first came back that
happened and then the insurrection on
the capitol happened so it was a very
very hard week to come back from
maternity leave and i just felt in the
moment i felt
i started crying and i had a panic
attack in my uh my um office downstairs
afterward i threw up it was a mess and
i just thought like
i just don't think this is well women
should be treated when they come back
from maternity leave and i felt also
like the camaraderie of the show had
dissipated and coveted because of
the satellite the fact that we were
physically apart from each other really
hurt the show i mean there's nothing
anyone could do about it obviously but
it did have an impact
[Music]
you